وموضوع انه الورم يساوي موت هذا غير صحيح
جزء من مشاكل الاورام تحتاج معنويات
المريض
وانا دائما اقول للمريضي انا وانت عندنا
هدف واحد لازم نقضي على هذا السرطان انا
وانت دائما اقول له انت ما انت بحالك انت
انا معك
انا وزان صالح الجني استشاري جراحه عظام
الاورام استشاري لي الان تقريبا حوالي 13
سنه دخولي الى هذا المجال الحقيقي قصه سبب
دخولي مجال جراحه الاورام تحديدا ان
الوالده الله يرحمها ويغفر لها ان شاء
الله وجميع موتى المسلمين توفت وانا صغير
في حدود العمر 9 سنوات بمرض السرطان اثر
فيني طبعا ما في شك وبالتالي كان دايما
حلمي اني اكون موجود ذيك الفتره واكون
طبيب وكنت ساعدتها وشفيتها باذن الله
سبحانه وتعالى
يوم العمليات هذا من احلى وافضل الايام
موجوده عندي انا اعتبرها كفن كالفنان لما
يحب يجلس يختلف نفسه ويقول قصيده ويرسم
رسم على نفس الشيء لما ادخل غرفه العمليات
احس هذا مكاني ما في شي اسمه عدد ساعات
عمل انا ما اذكر انه في عهد ساعات عمل انت
تروح تقضي عملك انتهى عشره بالليل ترجع
البيت عشره بالليل انت الساعه خمسه بالعصر
ترجع خمسه العصر انت ما تشتغل وانت ساكت
[موسيقى]
المساعدين فانت شلون تقابلهم كيف العياده
اربعين ساعه مع المرضى مشغولين في
العمليات لا عندك فرصه تتكلم سوالف تسمع
منهم وش اللي مضايقهم وش اللي مضايقهم ايش
صار في ما صار يعطونك اخبار المستشفى وزي
كذا
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه اول شيء لازم تكون هادئه مع
المريض
وتحاول تسال تتكلم بلغه المريض اذا كان
يعني صغير في السن تحاول تنزل لمستوى اذا
كان كبير في السن تحاول ترتقي الى الفكر
اللي هو يحتاج المريض لان الكلمات الطبيه
والمعلومات الطبيه الحين تكون بعيده عن
مريض الان عنده هدف معين انا وش عندي
وش مصيري
فانا دائما احرص اني بعد اني احاول اسال
مريض
بعض المرضى ما يبغى يعرف كثير عن تفاصيل
المراه
بعض المرضى لا يبغى يعرف كل شيء وكل صغيره
ويبدا يسالني بالارقام
مجهز اسئله العامل المشترك بين الاثنين
اني انا اعطيهم امل لكن انا ما حنذكر
المريض ان انت حتموت او اي شيء هذي امور
باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى
[موسيقى]
هذه هذه بنت عمرها 19 سنه جلست في البيت
ثلاث سنوات ما تتحرك حتى انا اسالها ليش
ما تجين امها اسالها ليش ما جبتوها من
بدري يعني
قالت يلا يا وليدي هذه بنت وتستحي وما
نبغى ما تبغى تجي المستشفى وتكشف قلت لها
قالت والله ما بدات تشكيله من بعد ست شهور
ومن بعدها جابوها المستشفى طبعا الورم
للامانه شيء يعني ما تصدق رجلها السليمه
جدا صغيره رجلها المريضه بشكل مخيف جدا
الحقيقي
للامانه اضطرينا يعني حتى نسوي لها بتر من
جهه الحوض من فوق الحوض
تخيل بنت عمرها سنه تسوي له بيت من فوق
الحوض
يعني حتى قدرتها على الجلوس
تصير ضعيفه جدا ما عاد جارتني من بعد ما
سويناها العمليه تابعت معي سنه والامانه
بعدها ما عاد شفته
حاله رجل
عمره في سبعين سنه وعنده ورم في الكتف
ويحتاج استئصال للكتف كامل
للامانه اللي رفض ولده ما هو فانا ذكرت له
قلت له ارجع انت واخوانك
وناقشوا الحاله بشكل جيد
رفضوا العمليه تماما ما اخذوا قرار لا
قالوا ايه ولا قالوا لا بعض احيانا يكون
خوف العائله منهم ياخذوا قرار يكون ضد
مصلحته والدهم ضد مصلحه فرد من افراد
تترددون في اتخاذ القرار الين يتاخر قرار
ولما يتاخر القرار بدل ما تكون استئصال
ننتهي نرجع لموضوع البتر مره اخرى
تدري ايش الاشكاليه عندنا مجتمعنا لان بعض
المرضى لما تخبرهم بالواقع اللي هو عليه
اول شيء يفكر فيه يبي يروح يتعالج على
الشعبي وللامانه واجه خصوصا اجتماعنا
واجهتني مشاكل كثيره كانه ممكن نساعد
المريض وللامانه بعد فتره بعد ما يخلص من
علاجه الشعبي ويروح ويغيب ويختفي ويرجع
الورم صار المقاسه اضرب في اثنين طبعا انا
وش اسوي في المراه يعني الناس اللي تذكر
موضوع العلاج الشعبي ما في مشكله بس لا
تترك علاجك
علاج المستشفى لا تتركه شيء بينك وبين
نفسك يخصك فالاورام العظميه غالبا لازم
تبدا بعلاج كيماوي بعد الا
هنا هي هنا تبدا مرحله اللي يسمونها
الدينايل عدم
عدم التثبت من الحاله فيروح يدور اعلان
شعبي لا انا ما عندي شيء انا طيب انا انا
اللي نبدا يكبر عليه الوراء فبعض الحياه
المريض للامانه وافكار بعض الافكار يعني
واهماله في الامور هذه تعدي الى انه يفقد
عضو منها ابائهم
طفل عمره ثلاث سنوات تقريبا جاب والده
ووالدته بعد استشاره وجدوا انه الورم
موجود في في منطقه الرسخ
وراحوا لبعض المستشفيات وذكروا ما في حل
للبتر في احد يبدو انه بدلهم على عيادتي
والحمد لله شفتهم وشفنا الاشعات وشخصنا
الحاله واضح انها ورم غير حميد فذكرنا
الوالد والد الطفل انه ان الورم هذا نقدر
نزيله ما يحتاج بدر والحمد لله بعد ما
سوينا العمليه ومشت الامور بشكل جيد الان
العمر الطفل عشر سنوات سبع سنوات وهو يوم
لا مناسبه الا يتصل يسلم علي لا زياره في
كل سنه في العياده الا وجايين معاهم هديه
يعني
صراحه فعلا حسيت اني انا فرد من الاسره
للامانه ما نقدر نستجيب للمريض يعني
فبالتالي نغير الخطه بس ما نستجيب للمريض
يعني تسالها طيب ليش ترفض ما تلقى عنده
سبب واضح
ولا منطق يعني للموضوع ليش ترفض
مع انه حتى الى الان لاحظ انا هذا اللي
انا مستغربه ان بعض المرضى ما سمع وايش
الاعراض الجانبيه حق العلاج هل هو قرا
عنها هل هو سمع عنها هل هو احد ذكرها له
لا يرفضك بغير ما حتى
احد يشرح له ايش الاعراض الجانبيه او ايش
نتائج الاعراض الجانب زي تساقط شعر الناس
تعرف انه في تساقط الشعر بس ترى الشعر هذا
شيء مؤقت بعد ما يخلص العلاج كل شيء يرجع
الوضع الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
يعني واحده من الاشياء اللي بنت عمرها عشر
سنوات
وشخصناها بورم في الساق
وبعد ما علمنا اهلها وبينا لهم الخطه
العلاجيه واوا فانا والمساعد قلنا لهم
يعني ان شاء الله فتره وتقضي المشكله ان
شاء الله بس يخلص العلاج نتسابق انا وانت
ان شاء الله
مع الوقت والايام الواحد ينسى الكلام هذا
وهو اخذت علاجها اللي تحتاجه وسوت العمليه
وبعد فتره اكثر من سنه من انتهى علاجها
الكيماوي والجراحي جت ها دكتور اليوم جاي
نتسابق انا وانت
شي يثلج الصدر فعلا ان انت حتى لما تكون
ناسي تتذكر كلامها
بعدين انتم المفروض الكلمات اورام تخوف
الناس انا خفت يا رجل
[ضحك]
حرام ليش
سرطان اي شيء يموت من بعدها الانسان يسمى
طاعون طاعون ترى مو محدود بشيء ترى
ايوه
[موسيقى]